[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
top
[Musique]
c'est l'aventuré ultime
je suis de toulon
dans le sud de la france
avec mon jumeau hughes nous sommes les
derniers d'une fratrie qui compte une
soeur clare devenu cantatrice et quatre
engins tous marins
enfant d'une mère institutrice et d'un
père musicien
ont grandi dans cet appartement déclaré
insalubre
on n'a pas de chaises autour de la table
on dîne sur des caisses en bois
mais pourquoi je vous raconte ce moment
parce que sans le soutien de ma famille
jamais je ne serais reparti
alors merci
en 2017
quant à armel le cléac'h pulvérise le
record de l'épreuve en 74 jours
le dernier en mai 124
et le dernier c'est moi
submergée de gratitude par ces dizaines
de milliers de personnes venus
m'accueillir en soi disant héros
ma décision est déjà prise
en 2020 mon bateau s'appellera merci
mais
il retournait pourquoi me demande ma
très chère mère
vous savez bien moment pour savoir si
j'en suis capable
et ton truc là c'est quoi au juste
après le départ des sables d'olonne vous
n'avez plus le droit de poser pied à
terre et personne ne doit monter à bord
dans la ligne d'arrivée
entre les deux vous foncez plein sud
vous faites le tour de l'antarctique et
vous rentrez à la maison
tu es en train de me dire que tu repars
faire un tour du monde en solitaire sans
escale et sans assistance c'est bien ça
mon fils
oui maman le vendée globe
c'est aussi simple que ça
en fait
quand on pénètre dans les quarantièmes
rugissants
où le vent souffle en tempête et les
vagues sont route comme des montagnes
on pénètre
dans l'univers impitoyable où la mort
rôde et notre présence est à peine
tolérés
d'abord il faut se farcir ce grand
sadique de ces indiens puis on passe au
sud du continent austral
avant l'immensité du pacifique et son
point le plus éloigné de toute terre
émergée le poids des mots
au bout du tunnel
la porte de la délivrance
le cap horn
50 jours
on passe 50 jours dans l'enfer des mers
du sud
là où seul reste l'espoir
vous êtes d'accord
on
ne peut pas dire ça une maman
alors merci
à moins d'un an du départ
les autorités change les règles et
déclare son ancien compagnon obsolète
j'emprunte un paquet de fric et avec
toute mon équipe c'est à dire mon frère
et moi on fonce à saint malo
là
dans un terrain vague il m'attend
c'est avec lui que je vais refaire le
tour du monde
mais d'abord on a jusqu'à fin août
pour terminer une qualification en
solitaire
seulement voilà
le matin du départ on s'aperçoit que
toutes nos voiles ont été volés dans la
nuit
j'appelle mon jugement
hughes mais le planning de sa voile rice
sont dessus dessous et m'apporte des
voiles de remplacement avec lesquels je
termine cette qualification in extremis
le 31 août à 5 heures du matin
alors merci
trois semaines avant le départ
merci est éliminé du vendée globe à
cause d'une batterie défaillante
ont bataillé avec l'organisateur et on
obtient un ultime sursis
j'ai jusqu'à minuit pour réussir les
cinq heures de navigation au moteur afin
d'éviter l'exclusion définitive
ce soir là
rené le contrôleur grimpe à bord et
alors qu'il déclenche son chronomètre à
18h43
il me dit
sébastien
c'est ta dernière chance
presque cinq heures plus tard à 23h31
tous les voyants du moteur passe au
rouge écarlate et on a encore deux
minutes à tenir
c'est long
c'est horriblement nom
rené vérifie son chronomètre
il est exactement 23h40 droit et je ne
vois aucune raison valable de refuser
son certificat il n'a pas fini sa phrase
que le moteur coupe brutalement
mais c'est dans la poche
et le 8 novembre 2020 jour de départ de
cette conquête de l'inutile
s'ouvre devant moi 45 mille kilomètres
de liberté absolue
alors merci
au large du brésil
je dois escalader les 29 m dumas pour
les enlever un des deux anémomètre qui
se baladent
c'est quand même un immeuble de dix
étages
pour un mec qui a le vertige
deux jours d'affilée j'abandonne
l'ascension aux deux tiers
ça secoue trop j'ai des bleus partout
j'appelle mon jugement
hugues me dit
tu te souviens il y a trente ans sur ce
petit bateau au championnat du monde en
baie de la baule on l'avait couché à
plat sur l'eau pour que tu grimpes en
tête de mât tu te souviens
que
t'es sérieux là
t'as vu la taille de merci je fais
comment seul
et ça change quoi
ça change quoi mais t'es complètement
cinglé ou quoi
en fait
à atteindre on prend un problème le plus
simple c'est de l'amener à soi
alors oui en plein milieu de
l'atlantique
j'ai couché le bateau et je suis aller
réparer cette bricole tout là haut
alors merci
dans l'océan 1
au large des kerguelen merci servent de
vannes en vagues
quand soudain on part en tête à queue le
pilote automatique a lâché
je saute sur le pont jean bouin la barre
tir d'un coup sec pour remettre le
bateau dans l'axé et là tout le système
de direction explose un peu comme si à
130 sur l'autoroute le volant de ta
bagnole de rester dans les mains
jusqu'en nouvelle zélande
je passe un mois à réparer merci
confinés dans ses entrailles un espace
à peine plus grand qu'une boîte à
chaussures et lugubre comme
un cercueil
huit fois le pilote automatique me
claque dans les doigts
huit fois on doit stopper en plein océan
huit fois je m'enfonce dans les
catacombes en passant
là ça va le faire
huit fois je suis la risée des terriens
assis devant leur télévision
et puis fois je me dis
mon pote
tu as beau - et je n'abandonne pas un
pote
alors merci
un océan
8000 kilomètres plus tard
une fois passée la nouvelle zélande
quelles sont mes chances de traverser le
pacifique
et d'attendre le horn
j'appelle mangement
vigueur
j'en peux plus
j'ai pas quoi faire tous les temps ac
j'ai dû sikaflex et de l'huile
d'hydraulique baraton j'ai pas quoi
faire
sébastien
il y à un mois quand ton système de
barre à péter c'était mort j'aurais
lâché la faire sans déconner tu ferais
tout longue pour que rool sur un bateau
dans un état pareil
non pas ça
à voir ben voilà
l'exploit ces arrivants gunhild en
nouvelle zélande devant toi tu as mille
toulon porquerolles pour rejoindre les
sables d'olonne tu vois quelque chose à
ajouter
peut-être temps pour moi
d'avoir une sérieuse conversation en
tête à tête avec moi même
j'observe ce pauvre mec assis là
je lui dis
tu peux y aller quand même
ça passe ou ça casse on s'en fout tu
peux tenter le coup
mais écoute moi bien
si tu fais ça
si tu décides d'y aller quand même
puis perdre à mon respect
ce pauvre mec
relève doucement la tête
il me répond avec ses joues
[Musique]
inondé de larmes salées
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]